robots people they are coming I'm
excited about this story there is going
to be the first advanced humanoid robot
it's about nine months off it is going
to feel like a human being it's gonna be
a service robot it's going to be
accessible to the public not just to the
super-rich so robots are coming this is
this is the science-fiction dream that
everyone has had for a long time so I
guess we're to start with this how long
will it take for them to become our
overlords Jackie yeah I'm wondering how
long it's gonna take till there's porn
with the robots and that's that doll
that actually moves and speaks when
she's being
Marsellus has been waiting for the male
version about how we can't stop taking
pictures of our food for five minutes
they are our overlords all right yeah
the robots rule is this rules me it's
the last thing I touched before I go to
bed the first thing I touch when I roll
up in the morning this and my cell phone
we are all slaves to something with
circuitry into the data I find this
really creepy and what I find even
creepier is that don't these people
watch movies
didn't you see iRobot with Will Smith
yeah you see that didn't end well didn't
you see artificial intelligence with
that creepy little guy from The Sixth
Sense that really didn't end well cuz at
the end the only people are left are him
the little creepy teddy bear and the
aliens that come down and they're like
oh the earth is now cold and barren and
there are no humans left a lot of people
still like that movie when it was a bad
ending it was an awful ending that can't
end well this will not end well this
will end with like some old lady being
choked by a robot this will end with
like some guy like finding himself like
finding a way to like impale a robot and
being electrocuted to death this won't
anyway okay now I agree with you I agree
with you the robot think and not you're
really getting a kick out of the most
whimsical bad ending of all time like it
is going to end badly but
or it's gonna be like that really bad
Bruce Willis Lee it's gonna be like the
Kember when the Cabbage Patch things
were a thing yeah rolling around like
Cabbage Patch dolls in their things and
they were actually naming them and they
were talking to them people are going to
stop talking to each other and they're
going to have the idyllic child who
happens to be a robot who actually has
blue eyes and blonde hair cuz I probably
have a little robot kid that had blue
eyes and blonde hair cuz I mean little
black girls and having to comb their
hair and stuff so anyway you're rolling
around with this doll and you're not
interacting with anybody you've got your
perfect robot baby and if you're me
you've got your perfect robot husband
who has like a six-pack abs and is like
six foot two and it's perfect and he
does whatever you want to do and there's
no backtalk and there's no where's the
credit card I want to go shopping this
will not end well people this is the
beginning of the apocalypse and it's a
robot apocalypse it's like Darth Vader
really when I selected this story I
really had no idea that it was this
level they're making them for when you
know you're growing old when you're you
know so you're by yourself you're
already in a nursing home the only
persons can be taking care of you is a
robot like it's not even a person they
oh yeah
so you're saying are you saying that's
bad no is this just because we all think
for some reason that these things
because of science fiction movies we all
think automatically this is just gonna
be all hell is gonna break loose when in
reality maybe a nice Oprah robot a nice
human contact about my mama a robot
instead of like the purse she wants for
Christmas now I'm supposed to buy her a
robot also and that makes me a bad [ __ ]
if I do do that who's gonna buy an old
person a robot it's going to be rich
people buying robots so that they don't
have to do anything they're gonna be
slaves it's gonna be a bunch of freaky
people who can't get a woman to do what
they want
buying robots it's going to be a bunch
of people who kill or barren buying
little robot kids and talking to them
like they're action real people this
will not
gonna be you know what it's gonna be
like I'm gonna make a robot of myself so
that I don't have to leave the house and
it's gonna be like that bad Bruce Willis
movie Wow
where they're like you know you're fat
you're morbid in your house bound
because all you do all day is eat and
you've got this thing on your head that
makes your robot go to work for you and
your robot is an idealized version of
you
so my robot now looks like Tyson
Beckford and is like you know buff and I
get to sit at home and do nothing but
eat Oreo and frozen Reese's Cups I think
we I'm pretty sure we just ended the
show David Lee of anything else you'd
like to couldn't possibly top it all
right Marcellus hold yourself for one
second I want to remind you guys that my
wardrobe is brought to you by bonobos
calm and you can enter code Reuben
reports to get 20% off your next order
they got shirts they got past they got
shoes they got underwear they got socks
all stuff for humans and for robots
alike that's right I want to thank
Marcellus Reynolds Jacki Monahan Dave
Holmes and I'm gonna let you guys pimp
yourselves out because I always feel
that the guests on these shows can give
a more intimate pimping than the hosts
Marcel's where can people find you you
can go to Marcellus Reynolds com well
tomorrow morning I will be selling robot
apocalypse t-shirts man moves quick
Jackie you can go to Twitter Jackie
Montana Twitter and Facebook of course
and Jackie Monahan calm and you can go
on iTunes and order my movie codependent
lesbian space aliens seeks aim high you
can find me on Twitter at Dave Holmes I
am verified a nota brag and I will also
be appearing at The Upright Citizens
Brigade la this Thursday the 21st a 9:30
Los Angeles cool well I thank you guys
for joining me on the first
pisode of the Reuben port watch out for
those rich gun-toting robots everybody
we will see you next week thank you